so I guess the the thing you have to
think about in any given poker situation
is that you're dealing with a lot of
uncertainty and it's all about how to
make the best decision in any given
moment so the first rule of thumb is how
to extract the most money or chips from
your opponent when you have a strong
hand and how to lose the minimum when
you have a weakened you're never going
to be 100% certain which you know where
you are you beating them or are you do
you have a worse hand so you have to
sort of construct a strategy that is
mathematically optimal in each situation
I guess people tend to think of
intuition as their gut their gut
instinct and my rule of thumb in poker
is to only fall on my gut instinct if my
sort of logical my slow brain you know
the system to err that sometimes called
has not come to a conclusive answer a
lot of people attempted to just go oh
this is too tricky I don't know and then
go yep well my gut instincts said this
I'm going to go with that but the best
thing to do is to work with both you'll
feel sort of slow brain and and that gut
so you'll say you're playing against
your opponent and you've noticed that
actually there's someone who is very
solid they never seem to Bluff
and you might have a hand that you would
normally call with saying ninety percent
of the time but you know this guy is
just he's just bluffing never doing it
well
actually this might be on those rare
situations where you do throw your hand
in the mark or you have a very strong
feeling you're just not like calling
even though mathematically it says you
should call you shouldn't do it so the
real I guess the art part of Poker is
when you have these flashes of
inspiration where you need to deviate
from the math and the science is knowing
how often you shouldn't you whether that
deviation is the right thing to do at
the time
when it when it comes to your intuition
as a poker player I would say do we use
it from time to time but it should not
be your your starting point you as a
rule of thumb should always go for the
slow method system to analysis see what
answer that comes up with and then also
check in with your gut so you're you
know in a really big hand and your
opponent has bet often all I'll have an
instinctive response might might I'll be
like oh that's a bluff or all that's
that they have a really strong hand and
I'll make a note of it I won't just go
with that answer
okay now let's look work through the
mathematics lips looks sort of through
all the other bits of information what
are they done in on other cards and so
on and then see if those two answers
match up now if they both match up great
I've got a got an easy decision but if
one is giving a conflicting answer to
the other then usually you tend to rely
on the sort of mathematics the majek
part however it's still really really
close with the mathematics then I'll
fall back on on that gut instinct but as
a rule of thumb your gut is not as
reliable as you think you you can see
these things like means on the Internet
which is like always going with your gut
trust your instincts and so on and I
personally think that's a cop-out I
think that's often the lazy way out so
just be when when we are faced with a
really tough decision in life or just
going oh well you know on taxing our
brains are are very they love to like to
simplify things to do things in black
and white but we live in a very complex
world and and that doesn't not you know
that's not always the best route to take
so in a nutshell your gut instincts can
be useful but as a last resort you know
we've evolved these amazing brains for
reasons so we should be easy
[Music]